any particular reason why my oncologist is ordering a PET scan after my four-week chemo holiday
versus a CT scan, which I normally use to. Um, yes, that because that is standard procedure.
So I can't remember if you received a PET scan before or not, but that's irrelevant.
Typical standard procedure is your, once you're diagnosed with cancer, they're going to start
chemotherapy, then typically a month after chemotherapy, you'll receive a PET scan.
And typically insurance won't cover a PET scan until after chemotherapy.
And the oncologist wants to know if there is metastasis anywhere else.
And if you didn't receive a PET scan prior to chemotherapy,
then he can compare if there was metastasis prior to chemotherapy versus post chemotherapy.
So that's the purpose of ordering a PET scan. Again, the value of a PET scan
is that you're going to see if there's an increased level of metabolic uptake
of the glucose from the PET scan in all throughout the entire body versus a CT scan,
which is just looking at structure, um, tissue structure in the area of the CT scan in its region.
So a CT scan is regional. Maybe we're going to do it abdominal or upper abdominal CT scan.
And but a PET scan is, um, throughout your whole body.